[Music]
morgan's in jacksonville florida
hey morgan what's up hey dave how are we
doing
better than i deserve how can i help
awesome dave first let me just say
thanks uh thanks for taking the call a
long time listener i grew up
my dad listened to you ever before uh i
could even understand what finances were
so well i got to finally get in thanks
financial peace baby yes sir yes sir and
i'm about 24 years old dave
i'm debt free never had a credit card or
a car payment
uh i bought my own used car a couple
years back and i'm currently renting uh
one bedroom apartment with my girlfriend
and my girlfriend and i are pretty
serious and i've actually fully funded
a savings fund for an engagement ring
that i plan on purchasing in the next
few months
and popping the question probably later
this year um
my dad's very traditional similar to you
in the sense that he doesn't even like
that her and i live together right now
before being married
and certainly doesn't think that merging
finances before marriage is a good idea
but i'm curious because she's in the
process of pursuing a master's degree
and with that is taking out some student
loans to do so
and so i'm wondering if it would be
beneficial for me to once we do get
engaged
start paying off our student loans as a
fiance and not a husband
prior to you know actually combining our
finances when we get married
because then you know i'd be able to
save money on the loans
ah man dave um man you know
here's the thing uh morgan i i i agree
with your dad i'm traditional like your
father
you know um and i don't have any kids so
but i think you already know that so we
don't have to go there
here here's my suggestion uh because
again i feel dave
eyes looking at me he's ready to say
something uh
watching you i'm watching you do your
thing you're getting so nervous i'm just
playing
um here's the thing man i would not
combine here's what i would do because i
hear it in your heart that you really
that you love your your young lady
and that you really want to uh help her
out and i'll put my business out there
right when i joined the team here dave
knows is i was engaged to an amazing
woman
and um we had some goals but what i did
not do i did not combine our finances i
actually had a savings account
that i was parking all the money on so
when we did get married
i would just cut the check and say here
babe let's go take care of this
of something that she had so i would
recommend that same thing for you
because morgan i'm single today and
unfortunately that engagement didn't
work out and i pray
that your engagement works out i pray
that you all do get married
but i would not combine the finances of
you and your your girlfriend today
if you have a heart for that because you
are say you are saved you are single
i always go ahead and put the money in a
separate savings account and then when
y'all get married
then go ahead and combine the check
that's my suggestion for you so that way
you're protected on both sides
if something doesn't go well cool you
still have the money if something does
go well and everything goes down the way
you want it
i think that's a great impression on
your wife key word there was wife
yeah and that's aside from traditional
that's more
just practical and legal
than it is spiritual or moral okay
uh we can go spiritual or moral but we
don't you know still answer the question
through the lens that you're
asking it which is um you know
it just it sets you up now let me give
you another one that is relational
and that is is that when you start
handing money
to people i don't care who the people is
that you aren't married to um it changes
the quality and the texture of the
relationship
so i have grown i i have children older
than you okay
so if i hand them ten thousand dollars
if i'm if i don't do that in a very very
distinct and clean way
it taints it colors the relationship
does that make sense
yes it does like they could feel like
they had to answer to me about where
they went on vacation then
even though i didn't say that that's in
the air
right and so it could it could
negatively
impact the quality of your engagement
if you go ahead and transfer funds from
a relational standpoint and that's apart
from the moral
or the traditional or the spiritual
element that your dad
and i would be concerned about which is
another different discussion
it's a same issue but different
discussions around it so
the practical aspect and i've seen
things worse than what happened with
anthony
here's a really weird one like people go
by houses together and they're not
married
and one of them dies in a car wreck
now your shacked-up girlfriend
owns a house with your parents
because you didn't have a will leaving
it to her and
you your assets go to your heirs
which would be your mom and dad now your
mom and dad are half owners with your
former shacked up girlfriend
you talk about awkward as crap that gets
weird very well and i've been in these
coaching sessions with
either the parents and they're going
what do we do with her do we kick her
out or
or you're with her and you're going to
yell at the future in-laws that never
really became the in-laws are now being
the people from hell
and you know oh my gosh it gets it just
creates all kinds of problems yes
so just keep everything separate dude
until you're married yeah when you come
back from the honeymoon combine
everything
and talk a lot about it talk about it
you can say
i got i got ten thousand dollars over
here waiting for when we get home from
the honeymoon
i got you know and we're gonna pay that
off that's what we're gonna do and you
know how's your budget going here's my
budget and
show each other what's going on but
don't combine them
yeah don't don't condone them and it's
gonna be a little difficult because you
are
you are you guys are living together and
so there
there will be a little temptation on
both sides because you're already living
whose mustard is that in the
refrigerator yeah i mean it's just a
problem but